alors en fait ça commence au départ on
vous fait la préparation des vols il y a
un bulletin météo qui vous dit voilà
c'est délicat il y a des turbulences le
vent et compte beau pour beaucoup parce
que on encaisse des ventes travers par
exemple jusqu'à 50 60 km/h mais pas plus
alors si vous êtes à la limite vous
essayez de vous poser et puis on est des
alarmes sonores à bord par exemple quand
on vous dit winchir c'est comme
quelqu'un qui est avec un marteau sur la
tête wincher ça veut dire six aliments
devant vous vous approchez vous pouvez
pas le savoir avant et puis bien il y a
des turbulences c'est assez désagréable
pour les gens qui ont déjà peur en avion
ça augmente le stress d'une façon
considérable tout le secret n'est pas
dans la procédure moi j'étais
instructeur pendant pas mal des dizaines
d'années et je disais à mes à mes
copilotes ou à mes pilotes faites une
remise de gaz au moindre doute vous
remettez les gaz et après une fois en
l'air vous réfléchissez vous déroutez
vous retentez peu importe mais informer
vos passagers c'est ça l'histoire c'est
que on se trouve dans les situations
particulières avec des gens qui ont peur
et bien il faut leur dire écoutez c'est
une procédure normale on passe trois
fois par an dans 4 heures dans un
simulateur et systématiquement on fait
des remises de gaz c'est un procédé
classique pour toutes les compagnies
en pilote automatique de gérer lui-même
ça et du coup il le pose tout seul ah
non alors là où il y a du pilote
automatique c'est en cas de brouillard
le vent de travers il sait gérer jusqu'à
un certain point ah d'accord et de toute
façon on reprend les commandes en manuel
en cours de finale pour pouvoir
d'écraber au bon moment d'écraber
c'est-à-dire on approche en crabe face
au vent puis au dernier moment faut pas
le faire ni trop tôt ni trop tard mais
ça on la prend tous les pilotes à faire
ça et c'est vraiment pas le danger n'est
pas là quoi non mais alors c'est ce qui
s'est passé le pilote il a il a c'est
l'erreur de qui il a raté son
atterrissage
vous avez une alarme qui se déclenche en
disant pull-up remettez les gaz parce
que on maîtrise plus parce qu'il y a
trop de vent il y a trop de turbulences
ou alors la piste est inondée ça arrive
il y a beaucoup de de cas de remise de
gaz la piste était inondée
[Musique]
une première fois pourquoi il a
recommencé puisque visiblement ça
n'allait pas changer dans l'espace de 5
minutes pourquoi la première
les les boîtes noires mais en tous les
cas il tente et puis il y a une
turbulence qui dépasse les autorisations
on est limité c'est réglé tout ça et
bien on remet les gaz et puis on appelle
le contrôle on appelle la météo pour
savoir le les dernières données sur la
piste en service et puis on s'est soucie
aussi du fait que la piste est
contaminée ou pas c'est à dire mouillée
ou pas par exemple ça diminue le
freinage et puis là bah on retente parce
qu'on y tient il y en a calmé on va
retenter bon il retente alors peut-être
aurait-il pu décider plutôt d'un
déroutement sur Montpellier c'est
possible mais ça pose d'autres problèmes
aussi alors on va écouter en premier
audio on en a plusieurs des pilote donc
toi tu la première approche se poser sur
Nice
l'approche la première approche est
ratée écoutez le témoignage de cette
passagère qui explique ce premier
atterrissage raté regarde
sur la mer pour faire son demi-tour
c'est complètement emporté par le vent
on sent qu'il y a plus de contrôle à ce
moment-là il y a pas de message ou le
pilote nous dit rien en fait donc on est
quand même dans le stress les gens
autour de moi aussi les enfants crient
donc c'est déjà assez compliqué alors
c'est vrai que là le pilote il doit
informer alors on n'a pas on n'a pas
compris si c'était avant la remise de
gaz ou après d'accord donc il y a un
doute
pour les téléspectateurs qui ont déjà
pris l'avion qu'est-ce qui se passe ça
veut dire que là il arrive il est à
combien il est il est bientôt en train
d'atterrir et là il repart en fait c'est
ça exactement donc vous vous sentez que
ça passera pas parce que la piste est
mouillée ou on va trop vite ou on une
rafale qui met du vent arrière donc ça
raccourci la distance de freinage il y a
1000 possibilités d'accord en fait que
vous soyez obligé de remettiez pas la
sensation
en montée vous remettez plein pot
plein
pot sur les manettes de gaz et puis vous
ça devient un décollage classique pour
les passagers
et là on est prêt à atterrir et là il
repart oui absolument qu'est-ce qui se
passe donc ce qui se passe
le début s'il vous plaît mais ça la tour
de contrôle
de l'avion qui est spécifique
au dernier moment et c'est vrai qu'il
faut des qualités de pilotage c'est
classique en simulateur on vous met au
maximum de vent de travers là il a vu
qu'il pouvait pas que c'était trop
touché donc il remet les gaz bon alors
là voilà ça prouve qu'il y a un vent de
travers qui est considérable à minima il
aurait peut-être fallu informer les
passagers de ce qui se passe parce que
c'est peut-être ça le secret de la faire
et moi j'ai toujours fait ça bon
j'espère que mes collègues le feront
aussi ou le fond aussi c'est informer
les passagers on le fait pas pendant la
remise de gaz parce qu'on a quand même
une surcharge de boulot on va pas mettre
en danger l'avion et sur Accident donc
une fois qu'on a remis les gaz et qu'on
est en altitude on explique mais il faut
vraiment expliquer ça c'est le secret du
métier et il y a que le pilote qui peut
le faire je vais poser une question
alors je voudrais qu'on écoute un
deuxième audio on a plusieurs la
passagère nous raconte ensuite la remise
des gaz donc ce que vous dites par le
pilote mais avec les turbulences et
l'atterrissage raté c'est la panique à
bord parce que l'avion bouge beaucoup et
là il remet les gaz forcément c'est la
panique écoutez
donc là il est chaud son premier
atterrissage en fait on part
complètement en arrière du coup il fait
sa remise de gaz donc là il nous dit
avec une voix qui tremble en fait quand
on atteint le ciel et les gens ils
crient quoi ils hurlent il y a une femme
enceinte trois rangs devant moi qui
s'évanouit savent que j'avais beaucoup
d'enfants à bord qui crie on a tous
mourir déjà c'est un peu plus d'angoisse
on va dire
donc là il meuble le pilote est-ce que
vous pensez que le pilote a flippé alors
la voix tremblante j'ai du mal à y
croire enfin bon bien sûr pourquoi pas
et puis il a il a un petit coup de chaud
ou pas alors c'est normal je veux dire
il est dans on a vu sur ces avions là
que vous avez fait voir à l'atterrissage
il est dans une position délicate il est
au crabe il a créé au bon moment il faut
le dire
heureusement alors après la deuxième
tentative que probablement il y a eu
d'autres avions qui sont posés et qu'on
témoignait en disant tu peux y aller
c'est une supposition tu peux y aller ça
s'est calmé il retente boum de recherche
ça marche pas il décide de dérouter non
pas sur Marcel mais si on Montpellier
parce que les conditions étaient les
mêmes donc les gens sont entraînés pour
ça et il y a mille façons
aux mille raisons plutôt de dérouter
parce qu'il y a la remise de gaz qui est
angoissante mais il y a aussi le
déroutement sur un aérodrome accessible
moi j'ai eu par exemple sur
des très très fortes turbulences ça
Hurley dans l'avion derrière j'entendais
bien et j'avais beau dire parce que
quand ça tremble beaucoup même votre
micro il tremble et donc c'est pas
évident on peut percevoir ça comme une
un bégaiement mais c'est pas du tout le
cas à mon avis et bien j'ai expliqué en
disant écouté on va retenter mais c'est
vrai que la situation météo est pas
terrible sinon on va dérouter et puis il
y a d'autres raisons pour dérouter moi
je me suis pris un vol d'oiseau par
exemple et bien ça
fendillait le l'enveloppe du radar
c'était pas du tout évident là aussi il
faut expliquer puis il faut s'adapter à
la situation les gens sont formés pour
ça quoi et je disais à mes pilotes il
vous arrivera toujours quelque chose je
signale quand même malgré mon voisin qui
me dit tu vas pas me dire encore que
l'avion est pas dangereux c'est quand
même 4 milliards de passagers pas un
seul accident les seuls accidents c'est
la voiture qu'il mène à l'aéroport donc
aujourd'hui et puis je dirais même pas
les gens monsieur c'est les gens qui ont
eu peur les pilotes conformé mais nous
quand on est dedans absolument je suis
d'accord il faut expliquer mon abo
expliquer des fois on entend pas la peur
absolument donc je conseille comme ça
repartir tu vois pour ceux qui ont peur
ici vous me téléphonez puis je vous
expliquerai plus alors on est grand
plaisir cette remise de gaz le pilote
fait un nouveau tour et tente un
deuxième atterrissage à bord les
passagers se révoltent et interpellent
l'équipage
à ce moment là en fait on sent qu'il
veut faire comme un demi-tour mais il
arrive même pas à tourner quoi il dit un
truc dans le délire bon on va réessayer
on va retenter à l'atterrissage tout ça
c'est hyper violent parce qu'en fait on
fait des Lego droit des hauts bas c'est
c'est violent c'est à dire que sans la
ceinture on finit la tête au plafond
quoi on sent que le pilote est pas sûr
de lui à 200 km heure devant on nous
rassure pas en fait c'est à dire que
maintenant je me suis dit c'est mon
stock quoi j'ai mal au cœur mon cœur il
a lâché il y a un Tintin qui avait son
truc dans un état pitoyable qui a les
histoires c'est bon changer d'aéroport
du coup on a tous gueuler on a demandé à
ce qu'ils sont dans l'aéroport et du
coup il a dit qu'il partait vers
Montpellier et donc là il arrive pas se
atterrir à Nice donc là il fait une
deuxième représentative donc là deuxième
tentative parce qu'il a dû avoir des
consignes les dernières météo où ça
s'est calmé peu importe en tous les cas
il retente il explique quand même qu'il
retente ce qui est déjà pas mal moi je
pensais que à vous entendre la dame et
il donnait pas d'information il les
donne au risque de faire de provoquer
une inquiétude supplémentaire donc il
faut faire attention aussi moi je me
souviens j'étais instructeur j'avais
lâché à lâcher ça veut dire qu'on fait
le dernier vol de contrôle le permis de
conduire si vous voulez sur un Caracas
première remise de gaz parce que avant
terrible et moi j'ai observé ça je
disais rien
pas d'annonce au passager mais moi
j'étais là en train de noter l'élève
deuxième remise de gaz et là ça
commençait à chauffer derrière et je lui
dis donc on ferait reste quand même
prévenir derrière ça fait partie de
l'apprentissage il y a une grande
sensibilité qui est mis à l'information
des passagers c'est primordial passagère
ancienne hôtesse de l'air était à bord
elle tentait de rassurer les passagers
mais confiés compte tenu de son
expérience que elle a pas été voilà
complètement
on va dire rassuré par le pilote
regardez
elle nous l'a dit qu'il a vraiment
vraiment pas géré ton truc j'irai pas
l'avion elle a l'habitude et en fait je
me suis rendu compte je peux pas tout
seul dans ma parano et au final quand je
suis passé dans la phase nuque
acceptation de la mort que sur la fin
j'étais sur quoi qu'on allait cracher
voilà donc elle nous rapporte le
témoignage de cette de cette hôtesse de
l'air c'est pas très sympa je trouve ce
qu'elle fait cette hôtesse de la oui
c'est pas dans les audio mais c'est ce
qu'elle a dit au passage
on peut dire de mon point de vue de ce
que je connais du vol il a fait le job
quand je dis il joue au pluriel les deux
hein parce que je vous rappelle qu'on a
quand même deux pilotes à bord il y en a
qui s'occupe de ce qui est périphérique
la radio la météo le radar etc et
l'autre qui pilote c'est où le copilote
ou le commandant de bord et là il y a ce
qu'on appelle une répartition des tâches
mais c'est essentiel pour une bonne
conduite abord de nos avions alors après
les deux atterrissage manqués la révolte
des passagers
moi donc été dérouté vers Montpellier à
plus de 300 km même si le vol est rapide
est passagers sont un peu traumatisé à
bord regardez
[Musique]
un peu tout le monde
c'est que elle a dû sortir avec les
pompiers en fauteuil roulant imaginez
les papiers psychologiques pour être
comme ça il y avait pas de blessure
physique on était bien attaché mais
juste les cas psychologiques en fait
alors et le calvaire n'est pas fini pour
les passagers qui se sont retrouvés avec
un énorme retard à Montpellier la 3
heures de route de l'aéroport les gens
du restit assis jusqu'à l'intervention
des secours c'est obligatoire alors s'il
y a eu des passagers blessés évidemment
c'est de la prévention ça c'est ça c'est
les autorités qui décident alors écoutez
on arrive sur Montpellier
on doit donc bien sûr être rapatrie
jusqu'à Nice ils disent qu'ils ont un
bus de 80 places pour deux ans passagers
ils disent la première idée premier
service bien évidemment que les gens se
mettent à courir et pousser pour rentrer
le car enfin c'est pas des choses qui
sont mais même pas un mec d'excuse rien
du tout impossible de lui joindre rien
alors il y a certains passagers qui
n'ont pas pu avoir le bus ils ont dû
prendre des taxis réglés près de 700
euros de taxi
parce que ça a été remboursé ça on croit
pas alors la compagnie prévoit de
rembourser que ce serait remboursé au
moment ça ne l'est pas d'accord va très
bien la réponse d'Air France une remise
de gaz quand l'avion ne se pose pas et
repart vers le sieste une procédure tout
à fait normale ce que vous disait dans
certaines conditions météo et
globalement quand on estime qu'il ne
faut pas mettre en risque les passagers
à bord voilà oui j'aimerais quand même
dire trois choses monsieur pardon un peu
plus fort trois choses monsieur la
première c'est que effectivement oui il
y a plus d'actionnes voitures mais un
action de voiture c'est 2-3 secondes tu
arrives à venir une descente en avion
quand tu commences à chuter tu sais que
tu vas mourir c'est une minute 30 c'est
très long quand tu sais que tu vas
mourir donc c'est une vraie panique la
deuxième chose le temps des ave quand je
monte dans un avion je regarde toujours
sur la gauche c'est une petite plaque
grise et vous avez la date de
construction de l'avion je passe mon
temps à avoir des avions qui ont 20 22
23 ans qui sont très vieux si Monsieur
beaucoup je regarde à chaque fois je
prends en photo et à chaque fois le test
de l'air me regarde et la troisième
chose qu'on dit je vous ai dit aussi
pour que les avions maintenant pour des
questions d'économie on met moins
descend de les avions pour qu'ils soient
plus léger et si il y a un souci qui
sont des routés ou quoi ils ont moins de
temps de vol possible donc pour toutes
ces raisons aujourd'hui pardon mais
l'avion c'est compliqué alors un avion
ça dure au minimum 20 ou 30 ans ils sont
ils sont
checker en permanence il y a des des
révisions générales on démonte tout
l'avion le monde
de 80 ans rassuré avec un avion neuf ah
bon parce qu'on a des défauts de
jeunesse que par rapport à un avion qui
est vérifié mille fois sur le sur
l'établi donc et quand ton carburant on
prend juste le nécessaire enfin je veux
dire que on n'est pas là pour bouffer du
carburant vous savez quand on prend et
c'est ce qu'on faisait avant quand on va
dans une destination le pétrole est
moins cher on a tendance à acheter le
pétrole pour le ramener à Paris on se
transforme en camion citerne mais pour
20 tonnes de plus de carburant vous
surconsommez 10 tonnes d'accord
il a pris suffisamment de pétrole en cas
de problème météo notamment et de
déroutement non seulement c'est
Marseille il est pas eu assez de
kérosène la cité des catastrophique
moi je trouve de critiquer comme ça
autant ce qui s'est passé il y a eu il y
a eu alors je suis peut-être con ou j'ai
pas pris assez l'avion il y a eu combien
de morts 0 il y a du vent il peut pas se
poser il repart moi ça m'inquiète pas
plus que ça les gens qui crient dans
l'avion sont pas capables de faire des
créneaux avec des tweets traumatisme
pour noter les spectateurs un truc ou
vraiment tu as flippé ou vraiment tu
t'es dit là ça y est on va on va oui
j'en ai plusieurs en tous les pilotes du
monde on fait des remises de gaz pour
quelques raisons que ce soit je parlais
des des oiseaux tout à l'heure et pas
que les oiseaux alors je vous dis les
oiseaux c'est un catastrophique pour
l'avenir qu'est-ce qui c'est alors un
réacteur et peut être complètement
pulvérisé on l'a vu pour Sully je sais
pas si vous avez ce film j'ai eu le
commandant de bord au téléphone j'ai dit
deux choses j'aimerais pas être à ta
place et en plus chapeau quoi avec un
jour il y a un avion qui a pulvérisé un
le pare-brise alors il y a une
pare-brise qui a explosé parce que
c'était un gros rapace et le Captain a
été inspiré par le vide et retenu à
temps par steward il a tenu les pieds il
a terminé son vol en décapotable la tête
en l'air ils sont des sorties je
rappelle Cyril qu'avant il y avait des
quatre réacteurs ça coûte trop cher on
fait des très gros deux réacteurs mais
deux réacteurs pardon quand il y en a un
qui tombera pas il y en a plus qu'un
quatre acteurs il doit rester trois à
chaque fois
petites choses là qu'on met ça devient
dangereux l'avion mais il y en a qui
disent que avec quatre moteurs on a
quatre fois plus de chance de tomber
encore
alors juste il y a eu un nouveau
raconter un quelque chose que vous
pouvez raconter au téléspectateurs un
jour le moment où vous savez le plus
peur de votre vie en tant que pilote de
ligne c'est quoi c'est un monsieur qui a
voulu mettre ça alors c'est pas
technique c'est humain et j'en ai les
larmes aux yeux à chaque fois que j'y
repense un passager qui voulait se
suicider il a réussi à rentrer dans le
cockpit il m'a coupé mes quatre moteurs
un avion sans moteur c'est pas une
situation d'avenir et ce sont des choses
sur lesquelles il faut réagir d'une
façon adéquat
l'équipage était devenu fou parce que
lui pour le coup mort de trouille et il
a fallu gérer ça donc on a dérouté sur
Bordeaux on a laissé sur Dakar et il a
fallu gérer les passagers mais c'est un
problème humain avant tout et là aussi
j'avais beau passagers il y en a un qui
m'a pris par le col il m'a dit tu as tué
mon frère j'ai dit mais c'est contraire
et il me dit non mais c'est pareil j'y
mets moi aussi c'est pareil j'ai fait ce
que j'ai pu pour le sauver j'ai fait ce
que j'ai pu pour sauver l'équipage et
les passagers on peut toujours faire
mieux mais franchement c'est quelque
chose que j'ai souhaité à personne oui
si vous pouvez nous rassurer encore un
peu tout à l'heure vous avez parlé de la
formation des pilotes là c'était Air
France moi je veux savoir quand on prend
des low Costes est-ce que les pilotes
sont sont formés de la même manière
trois fois par an si je prends Ryan si
je prends Transavia easyJet est-ce que
c'est la même formation pour les pilotes
alors d'abord les avions sont très
récents sur les locos moi je vais pas
attaquer les locaux mais en plus les
pilotes la difficulté ce sont des
pilotes qui viennent du monde entier
donc il y a un problème linguistique qui
peut arriver et puis des compagnies
comme Ryanair par exemple mais il y en a
d'autres et bien il calcule au centime
près évidemment
pas des avions dangereux et les pilotes
sont formés comme la réglementation
l'exig et ils sont quand même surveillés
donc non il y a pas de problème
particulier sur le low cost ceci à ceci
près la fatigue des pilotes où on les
soumet à des conditions de vol un peu
partout alors
crash d'avion les trois conseils pour
augmenter les chances de survie trois
conseils être assis à l'arrière de
l'avion donc il y a aucune chance
[Rires]
tous ceux qui sont en first ou ceux qui
sont business c'est pas bon une étude
effectuée sur 20 crash aériens à
démontré que les passagers assis à
l'arrière à des 69% de chance de plus de
survivre 69% les sièges situés aux issus
de secours sont aussi intéressants en
cas d'évacuation plus vous êtes près
d'une sortie de secours plus vos chances
sont élevés de vous sentir indemne mais
vous voyez c'est mieux d'être à
l'arrière de l'avion
en premier ils vont pas mettre la
première derrière il part du principe tu
auras pas de crache
commentaire
depuis que je l'ai de plus en plus
je te jure le cerveau
écoutez les consignes de sécurité même
si c'est peut paraître chiant pour
beaucoup de monde écouter les consignes
de sécurité donnée par l'équipage on va
le décollage que c'est vrai que là elle
a dit un truc elle a dit on avait nos
ceintures si on avait pas eu nos
ceintures euh elle a dit qu'on était et
c'est vrai que on dit souvent mettez vos
ceintures on les voit vérifier tout ça
on vient chez toi ça va parce que moi je
me dis souvent ça va changer quoi que je
mette pas de ceinture si l'avion se
crashe mais en fait pour les turbulences
comme ça je trouve qu'il y a des
consignes de sécurité vidéo maintenant
qui sont sacrément bien faites
quelquefois drôle d'ailleurs mais moi je
regarde même chez moi comme ça
je me sens qui tu vois je suis comme ça
et porter des vêtements au coton quoi
avant pourquoi et oui
voilà en cachemire dans l'avion telle
Matthieu Delormeau c'est non les
vêtements totaux sont nettement moins
inflammables que les matières
synthétiques les manches longues et
pantalons sont des protections
supplémentaires les vastes les baskets
voilà permettent d'évacuer vite voilà on
peut les enlever vite les baskets aussi
donc on a généralement moins de 90
secondes pas de talon pour éviter de
crever les toboggans d'évacuation moi
c'est ce qui m'est arrivé la dernière
fois voilà
quand on fait à Paris les riches payent
un peu plus cher mais il meurent en
premier
Nancy et qu'on nous explique comment
mettre un gilet de sauvetage c'est sûr
de surtout dans une piscine qu'est-ce
que que
il y a pas suffisamment d'accident et
heureusement pour faire des statistiques
là-dessus donc je suis un petit peu
réservé alors il y a les compagnies
aériennes les plus sûrs
on a tendance à parler sécurité sûreté
ce qui est pas tout à fait pareil et
confort à bord d'accord et les pires
compagnons n'est pas l'airlines
Airlines PNJ bon voilà voilà il y a les
blacklists effectivement moi je vous
conseille pas trop d'aller prendre
l'arnaque Royal n'est pas l'airlines
Corporation j'étais pilote à bas donc je
sais pas c'est catastrophe c'est pas
évident quoi il y a eu
il faut aimer le danger l'avion mais tu
dis tu as une chance sur deux
alors il y a des formes
il y a des déroutements où on met les
passagers dans la boucle c'est pas
évident j'ai fait un vol pas de toilette
ça paraît pas évident j'allais sur New
York ah ouais et puis vous savez que les
toilettes c'est par aspiration donc
quand il y en a une qui se bouge ben
c'est tout arrangé donc on me dit il y a
tout le côté droit il y a pas de
toilette c'est chaud il reste au côté
gauche c'est très bien PAF du côté
gauche ah ouais mais tu sais il y a
trois ordinateurs à bord il y a le fioul
contre lyonnais le fioul qui passe
devant en arrière pour équilibrer
l'avion il y a le fly control younite
c'est les commandes de vol électrique et
il y a ce que je ne savais pas le flush
control youth c'est l'ordinateur des
chefs d'eau donc je contacte Édimbourg
Glasgow les aéroports en disant vous
avez des toilettes alors le contrôleur
me dit il était un peu étonné quand même
bien sûr que j'ai des toilettes
stratégie vous en avez suffisamment pour
250 passagers bon il m'a accueilli quand
même des fois ça devient cocasse
c'était pas possible ça mais c'est
incroyable